how you doing jack before we get started
I've bought you a gift brother you did
yes ever since I've been on quarantine
I'm into carving and you know clay
models and stuff and I made this for you
it's called the shack angel oh my God
look at that as you can see the ABS are
intact as you can see the wings yes and
I also made one called the Jack warrior
this one right here oh my god these are
fantastic I can't wait to actually have
one of those in my possession you're
gonna say yes I will and I have one more
or carving that I did and once you see
it oh yeah okay let's call Shaq loves
the kids I did this one in about 30
minutes as you can see Shaq with the
kids I see there's you with the kids and
into those wings do you always have
wings in these yeah
yes because I'm an angel man wait I got
one more carving of Charles Barkley that
I did I see a Charles Barkley carving
yeah yes this is a Charles Barbee baby
yeah I see him I see it you said once
that back when you were playing back in
the day there were certain players that
you would let score on you because you
really respected their game is that true
not respect their game because I like to
their game so for example let's just say
Tracy McGrady is going against Kobe I
say okay Tracy McGrady two or three
plays let me see what you got and then
like you know I said whoa Kobe just you
know I'm saying boo Kobe just scoring
what you gonna do so I will let it go
three at the four position
Allen Iverson was another guy my go
ahead Kobe garner or D Fisher Carter
white chocolate Jason Williams was given
four in mind he was a number because he
was very fancy with the ball only time I
did do that was when I was in playoff
mode but other than that yeah like look
even though I'm a player was a lot of
guys I really respect that and I was
fans at this game
regarde so if I was playing now I will
let Steph Curry's go all the time I love
this game he's my favorite player